c'est la sixième édition de la journée
entrepreneuriat étudiant qui se
déroulent cette année à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
le public concerné par cette
manifestation c'est l'ensemble des
étudiants qui ont un projet
entrepreneurial qui soit en début de
projet ou qu'ils sont soit déjà la
création de l'entreprise
le but c'est qu'ils puissent donner de
la visibilité à leur projet et avoir le
point de vue de personnes aussi diverses
que effectivement d'autres entrepreneurs
des structures d'aidé à la création
d'entreprise des spécialistes des
experts est tout simplement aussi leurs
collègues étudiants ma tatie fabrique
des pâtisseries
industriels sans allergènes pour les
enfants ce sont des pâtisseries qui
exclut cet allergène les oeufs le lait
le butane ont des arachides les prix à
coke le maïs et le soja est aujourd'hui
en france la plus en plus d'allergies
alimentaires chez les enfants donc c'est
vraiment ce qu'on veut combattre et on
veut que les enfants allergiques et
leurs produits gourmands les avantages
de cette journée sont multiples encore à
tout au long du salon rencontrer
différents entrepreneurs mais aussi des
professionnels
suite à ce salon va également réaliser
un pitch donc ceci nous permettra
d'avoir d'abord d'exposer
dès le projet est d'être au contact
encore une fois d'avoir les avis de
nouveau
ensuite on peut également profiter du
retour de nos droits de personne en
photo à bouder les produits et on
comprendra toutes les critiques à la
fois policy mais négatif qui nous
permettront de faire avancer
faute au tir le fait d'être accompagné
par l'agro paris tech énormément aisée
mais d'encore et m'a permis de
rencontrer annie ce qu'on fait
bien avancé dans le projet en plus
l'agroparistech maaf a confié ensemble
c'est une première mieux qu'on trouve
qu'ils ont organisée donc ça aussi
c'était un beau soutien financier et ça
m'a bien aidé on sent que cette
génération de jeunes à la fibre
entrepreneuriale peut-être plus que les
générations précédentes et c'est vrai
que d'une année sur l'autre
nous avons toujours plus de projets en
tout cas on a tout mis en oeuvre pour
essayer de favoriser cette et
l'entrepreneuriat